口先で農書で指導し始めた時に組織は衰退
していきます私は今でも1番セルス強い
ですよこれすごく大事なことなんですよだ
から赤字っていうのはもう鼻血と一緒だ
からもうずっと出続けてたら死んじゃうよ
青木サの人生経営哲学100回聞いたら
豊かになる
話今回はですねまプレイングマネージャー
によくあることなんですけれどもま自分
自身がプレイングなので成果を出さなけれ
ばいけないとでも同時にそのメンバーを
育ててチームのパフォーマンスも出し
なさいと言われた時にこの自分の成果と
育成をどうやって両立させればいいのかと
いうことについて教えていただけますか
[音楽]
うんまこれ非常にシンプルだよねあれか
これかっていうこういう発想じゃないんだ
よあれもこれもなのよこう順番があるのよ
1番大事なのは現場で人を育てるというの
が1番確かなんですよだから私はま自分
自身セールスマネージャーの時に私が使っ
てたトークをメンバーに教えてメンバーが
撮ったアポに私は同行しましたそして
フロントトークという最初のまクラッチ
合わせをしフロントトークがありまニード
ストーリーがあってプレゼンテーションに
入りま反論処理をしてクロージングに入っ
て契約いただくとまその後フォローという
ことになるんだけどもまセールス
マネージャー時代のこと今思い出してるん
だけどねその時に必ず私は同行して育てて
いったこれをフィールドトレーニングて
言うんですよで力がないとイエスを見せれ
ないじゃないでイエスを見せれない人間が
口先で農書で指導し始めた時に組織は衰退
していきます昔から20代から変わらない
い私の信念マネージャーの現役度が組織の
活力そして自分ができないことを自分以外
の人に自分よりも立派にやらせることほど
難しいことはないだからまず自分が常に
戦闘を切ってあるレベルまでは現場型の
指導をしていくってことそれがリーダー
クラスですねで上に行くとどうなるかって
いうとメンバーをたくさん持ちますから
メンバーをたくさん持つっていうことは
そのたくさん持ったメンバーを育てて現場
で行かせるわけですよ同行させるわけです
よそうすると自分はもうマネージャーじゃ
ないですかでだんだん上がっていって刑事
になるんですよ私は今でも1番セルス強い
ですよこれすごく大事なことなんですよ私
はトップセルスマンです今でもそんな60
代でそうですです私は反論処理にしろ
セールスのデモンストレーションでも今で
も見せれますそれができなくなったら現役
度がないってことでしょでことは能力開発
コンサル会社としてそんな現役度のないね
おじさんがだね偉そうに喋ったら衰退する
に決まってんじゃん私はね常に現役です
未だに3日間の研修を立ちっぱなしでやり
ますきさすごいですね3日間も何がすごい
のって当たり前じゃないってこれで飯食っ
てんだろうとそ3日ぐらい立ちっぱなしで
メッセージできなくてどうすんだよとそれ
も1ヶ月に1回じゃないかといやだからな
んだろうなこう基準が違いすぎちゃって
もう話にならないのよ俺この間ちょっと
YouTube見たら大谷翔平さんの食事
のことずっと出てたんだけど当たり前じゃ
ないかと思うよ俺TPOでえ炭水化物取る
食事タパ質中心の食事すごいってびっくり
したそれ基準が違うんだろうね体作ろうと
思ったらやっぱりその体作ることを目的に
メニュー作るでしょう当たり前ですよね
ベストコンディションはプロの基本体です
そのマネジメントっていうのは人を返して
最終的には仕事を行う技術ということなん
だけど下が育ってないのに会社ごっこし
ちゃだめだし下の人間が育ってないのに
もう下に任せて自分は高みの見物これダメ
です常に降りるんです私はもう常に現場を
掌握してます何が起こってるかよく分かっ
てます私はその中でお客様から見たベスト
のサービスを未だににこだわってるから
社長が
成り立つで次の大の人間はそれをやる人間
ですありがとうございますものすごく組織
化していくのに時間がかかるんじゃないか
なっていう風にこう思ってしまうんです
けれどもなんかやっぱりこう時間をかけて
育てていくしかないんですか
[音楽]
ね会社を急激に大きくすることの意味って
何がなんで会社急激に大きくしなきゃいけ
ないのってことなんだよお客様から見て
及びじゃないってことですよお客さん求め
たのはクオリティなんだようちだって37
年もかかってんだよ今のこの組織体作るの
にあくまでも適正能力のある人間をその
ポジションにつけてそのポジションの人間
にその人間にあった人材をやっぱり配置し
その適材適所だよねそれを追求して経して
いるからおかげ様で今ね売上60億経常力
20億の組織体になってるわけですよいや
本当だ今260社あってあるってことは
260ま人社長がいるわけじゃんその中で
本当にいい経営者って2割じゃない
の2割の経営者が8割の成果出してんだよ
全体の8割で2割しか出してないだから
赤字っていうのはもう鼻血と一緒だから
もうずっと出続けてたら死んじゃうよ止血
しないとじゃどうしたらいいかってつっ
たらまず入りとのバランスをしっかり取っ
てね自分自身が率先してまず稼ぐことです
よ僕は未だに営業強いもんね絶対にうん
自信ありますようんなんでか
だってお客様のためになるもの売ってるん
だもん持っていたいても持っていただか
なくてもどちらでもいいもんでもない必ず
お客様には喜んでいただこうと真心持って
価値ある商品を作るわけじゃないですか
作ったら売るってことだよ売ったら今度は
管理するってこだよこういうこう哲学って
いうか現場型の経営者は現場型の管理職を
育てるんです
[音楽]
よまだからさ自分の器を拡張していき
ながらできもしないことをやろうとする
必要はないまず誰でもできることを誰も
できないぐらい立派にやり遂げていく
そして実を積み上げて結果気がついたら
大きくなってるというのは中身のある組織
ってことですそういう組織を心がけていく
ことが大切じゃないですか現場の中に答え
はあるっていうことが私が言いたかった
ことですねよろしいでしょうかはいま
コメント欄にもコメントよろしくお願いし
ますそしてチャンネル登録よろしくお願い
しますえところでですね今日私こう熱く今
伝えました現場型のマネージャー実はです
ねえ2006年に新卒で入って今アメとの
新卒から役員になった橋本拓也がですねえ
ボットで今リードマネジメントというえ
これをやってますので是非皆さんこっちの
方にも是非ね飛んでいただいて
YouTube見てくださいえ橋本拓也ね
リードマネージメントですま是非応援して
あげてくださいよろしくお願いし
[音楽]
ますあのねいいこと教えてあげる
キングダム見た方がいいよマジに大き将軍
1番強いんだよ1番強い人が壮大省なん
です弱っちいのが壮大省になったらどうな
んだその軍はわらべしってのがいるんだよ
ね奴隷の子から今将軍目指してんだよ
ともかく練習するよともかくそして武幸を
上げるために一生懸命頑張ってるよで
ちっちゃな体だよ最初今起震体っていうの
持ってるわけよねだけど一生懸命る
ものすご最前線で走って馬にも乗れねえん
だからまだだけど実績実績実績実績実績で
上がってくんだよそしてね可いがられるん
ですよだもう俺これ当たり前じゃないのだ
から1番気をつけなきゃいけないのは2代
目3代目です何の能力も保証もなかったの
にただ息子だからと後継ぐ俺はいつも言っ
てるわけね飛行機は残せても操縦技術は
本人がちゃんとパイロットになるための
訓練を受けなきゃだめだよってそうじゃ
ないと墜落しちゃうよと本当にそう思って
ますだから2代目3代目ほど勉強しなきゃ
ダメなんです創業者ってのはね自分の器の
中でとりあえずやってってだんだん大きく
してったからもう私も典型的な例でしょだ
からもうまさにこの中身のあるすごい
こだわった経営をやるわけよもう細かい
ことまで全部うるさいですよそれこそうち
なんかこのねバっと歩いててシミ1つあっ
たらこのシミ明日まで綺麗にしときなさい
とこのシミに私が気がつく前に気がついて
掃除ができるようになったら心昇格は
できるんだよぐらいまで言っちゃうぐらい
すんごい細かいです私はそういう文化を
作っていくのが経営なんですようんだ率先
炊飯じゃなくなったら引退じゃないのだっ
てなもうみんなそうじゃん長森さんにしら
の日本電産の長森さんみんな率先水飯
でしょ柳さんにしろユニクロの全部偉大な
経営者全部現場型じゃない柳さんなんか
月曜日絶対全世界が同じ会議に出るのよ
あれユニクロ全てそこの場で決断してく
わけでしょバリバリじゃないです
かいや僕絶対そういうもんだと思うよだ
から会社ごしてるが世の中多いんだよ